bonjour et dames et cinéma les
paysagistes ou jeudi l'insee explique
azote comme enrichir le sol
après avoir délimité le massif donc on
va pouvoir commencer à mélanger le sol
afin de l'enrichir pour que la plante
puisse s'épanouir tranquillement et pour
se développer normalement c'est un
amendement c'est à dire enrichir le sol
avec une matière organique ou minérales
moi je vais partir plus sur de la
matière organique afin de protéger
l'environnement et de pas couler le sol
quand je parle de match organisé le
compass le terreau déjà d'un contre ou
dans les supermarchés du de la paille
voilà tout ce qui divise talent fait et
on gagne ou déchets animal aussi je vais
semer à la volée sur la surface sur le
sac il ya les deux âges préconisez donc
à vous de voir s'il faut vous mettre
vokoun a en fait
ensuite on va passer au mélange c'est à
dire je vais labourer la terre pour que
la matière organique puissent pénétrer
dans le sol à brands hatch vélo et
respire bien avant parce que là ça va
transpirer
c'est une technique basique as et on va
fin labourage manuel avec la pioche tout
simplement
donc voilà vinea surface alors
profondeur aller tout doucement et
prendre son temps afin de faire un beau
travail et d'avant un bon résultat non
suffit de prendre du plaisir et prendre
son temps
le labourage et fait donc là je vais
passer on va égaliser la terre afin de
pouvoir disposer les plantes
et en même temps enlevé les gros rush
qui jeunes
quitte à tous utiliser le dos du râteau
a fait de vraiment bien égalisé la terre
pour le parent 22 p and o en fait donc
lors des grosses pluies ou de l'arrosage
bien égalisé à surface surtout enlever
les petits rochers qui gêne en fait je
prépare son habitat en fait pour qu'ils
puissent ces paniers à c'est un végétal
végétaline et vivent donc il faut tout
lui donner pour qu'ils puissent
s'épanouir tranquillement le plaisir est
de toucher 7 et à la qui est qui et
sookie est temps qu'ils aient poussé
heureuse et les prends du plaisir à le
toucher quoi c c'est ça la nature